the reality how bad of a situation is
that
oh yeah it's i thought i was gonna die
i actually should have died wow how old
were you at that point
um
it was 11 years ago so 35 wow and would
you share that's what were you doing
what was it by the way he said it so
subtly 11 years ago i was 35 meaning
today you're how old 46. i would have
never freaking guessed this guy's 46.
seriously
i wouldn't ever forget these four even
jennifer yesterday i thought you're in
your late 20s
[Laughter]
not jennifer your wife jennifer my wife
yes so you're both jennifer's okay yeah
david's
so you wanna you wanna uh tell him
because he asked your question yeah we
can we can dive into that um
i'll just summarize you know uh not
walking with the lord trying to do my
things my own way
the you know my go-to's were alcohol and
then when your party starts to get a
little bit long it's coke and it keeps
the party going
and uh so i had been that had been doing
that we were living in southern
california orange county and a
a friend of mine that uh
we would party together
we went out to go get some uh coke this
one night and we got it and it wouldn't
chop up
and i know this is not just r-rated
right but everybody's seen the movies at
least you know cocaine chops up it's
powder it wouldn't chop up
and it was just kind of mushy
and he said well let's just smoke it and
so we smoked it and it was unlike
anything i'd ever tried before and then
uh and then he's all how you like that
and i was like oh that was different and
he's all that was good i believe that's
free basin it was crack yeah yeah okay
so that started about almost two years
where i kept it from my wife brother for
the most part but i lost about 50 pounds
i continued to lose you're a big dude
what 65
yeah six four 250 255.
um and you went down to what
okay my high school weight
so my wife didn't know what was going on
she uh we moved back to reading you were
doing this without her knowledge
whatever yeah i was doing it at night
um and uh or just i was i was working on
road crews a lot so we'd leave for a
week or two
so we moved back to reading and within
like a month she just knew something was
wrong i found a new friend misery loves
company right i found a new friend i
used to do coke with and told him i was
doing crack and he's like i want to try
it i was like that's at first somebody's
like wanting to try crack i would have
never said sure give me some crack until
my buddies just like here smoke it so um
that
my wife moved out took the kids
and she's like i don't know what's going
on but i know it's not right and we
would just be up like all night and into
the wee hours in the morning four or
five hours consumed your life is what
you're saying oh yeah i would still go
to work i would try to go to work during
the day
which was my business life was just
falling apart i was a bus a business
owner at the time and you're in your
mid-30s at this point so it's not like
you were some kids and a college kid you
were a grown ass man with a family man
yeah
wow
so my wife reached out to an old friend
of ours and said jeff you've got to talk
to david jeff we've known for he's one
of my oldest and dearest friends uh
strong believer when i went and met with
him uh he later told me he said you know
that king in lord of the rings that had
the spirit of death on him
he's like that looked like you
he's like i could see death on you
this was later i'll get to what happened
so we had that talk and then
one night i was with my friend uh that
we were just staying up and playing
games and smoking and you're not
supposed to you're not supposed to
you're supposed to exhale pretty quick
once you hit it and you try to i'm
always trying to push the envelope and i
inhale it and kept it in a little bit a
little too long i guess and my eyeball
started going up and down like that fast
like you can't make your eyeballs go up
and down that fast
and in that moment
i
i know i heard god's voice just saying
don't freak out
this will pass
this will pass and so i didn't look at
my friend sitting across the table
because i knew he'd freak out
like i would freak out if i saw
somebody's eyeballs doing that right
yeah
it lasted about 60 seconds
and then it just subsided went away
so the next morning i called the friend
that introduced me to crack and told him
what happened
and he said david if you would have
freaked out and panicked your heart
would have exploded your body was
overdosing
so it was about two weeks later
if you can believe that but
it was about two weeks later that i had
finished doing all the drugs i had which
was fronted to me actually
i finished it all and then uh it was
saturday night i was done
and i just said god i made an absolute
mess of my life
my wife's gone
business is shut down what do you want
me to do
and i heard him say go to church
and this is now sunday morning i'm
having this argument so to speak with
god
and i finally stopped arguing so it was
like i had nothing
i was absolutely just
just destitute and and uh broke
so i stopped arguing with god
i went to church it's a large large
church in reading called bethel church
and that was a church i used to go to um
i share that just to say it's very large
and the road that leads to the church is
like one road and it only goes to the
church
so i got in the car i turned on caleb
i think that's what the guy was
listening to on my uber on the way here
actually today
i'm listening to caleb and i just
started weeping i just started bawling i
was just like i'm just broken so broken
i drive the cars are lining the side of
the street that the church is so packed
i get to the church i get to the top
cars everywhere
and then i and i see a sign that says
parking lot full and i keep driving and
the very first parking spots open so i
park
i walk inside they had the overflow was
just packed in the lobby and the church
was totally packed service was probably
just done with worship so it's probably
going for an hour
i look in the auditorium and no seats
anywhere and i get a tap on my shoulder
this lady's like you looking for a seat
you can have mine i'm right in the
middle third row from the left
on the left
so i'm kind of like looking up like okay
i got a seat i got this parking spot i
go and i sit down as soon as i sit down
the pastor comes walking out and he says
today's message i'm going to talk to you
about the prodigal son coming home
and walking into his inheritance talk
about timing
total total god thing right total papa
thing so i hear the message i talked to
a couple pastors that i knew that were
right there chris valatin and a couple
others told them what i was dealing with
cracked told them i almost oded
and
chris actually prayed for me and it felt
like his hand just sunk into my my sunk
into me
and um never the same after that never
touch crack cocaine again
and then cold turkey boom you're done
turkey after one 11 years yeah well
eleven years ago yeah i was doing it for
two years have you touched alcohol since
anything since yeah yeah i still dab a
little bit of alcohol quit that about
three years ago
and then my wife and i quit together
which has been amazing almost a year ago
so that's been a strong thing because it
was hard
being married at least for us we were
kind of codependent we got married young
right i was 18 she was 16. that's a
whole other story
but uh we grew up together and then
having issues
it can be easy to just you know
she's doing it i'm doing it we'll both
do it although she never did crack we
used to do other stuff together
but um
so god is good man he just his mercy is
real his forgiveness is real his
restoration is real i wouldn't be here
today if it wasn't for him and uh now
i've got this platform so anyway that's
it's crazy the stories last couple weeks
by the way right i mean it's not even
intentional it just kind of goes uh into
it the last two podcasts yeah right even
the pascal podcast with gerard and
jarrah's not even a uh
believer there are just uh you know
there's a guy who well gerard story is
insane
his story about how he got stabbed and
how he doesn't drink hard liquor anymore
and gerard's got and you kind of got to
get to the lowest point to
redeem yourself thank you for sharing
that brother i appreciate you a lot of
commentary here is blown over by the
story adam what's the worst uh uh or
health condition you ever had where
you're like dude this is this is nothing
comes close to this this sucks yeah well
luckily i've never had anything like
that before uh i have partied my ass off
in south beach but i've always known my
limits so i've never been into the
powder been more into the uh
the green at the end of the night you
know like money
yeah the money i spent money money's
grown on trees so luckily i've never had
these issues i've never had this fall
from grace or these you know major uh
hills and valleys i think i
the worst
yeah covet was pretty bad because it was
the worst for three days i could not
move i just
glued to my bed and i think i think i
had the a bad flu one time before but
luckily i've been blessed with good
health feel flu shot flu shot 20 years
old
because because uh you know playing
division one basketball they wanted
everybody to take the flu shot and i was
like man i don't really want to do this
but at 19 you know freshman year i took
it
i didn't feel so good then and then
sophomore year comes around and i'm like
like really bad
for like 10 days
so i had to go to like the uh
you know they on campus they have like a
you know medical facilities and that and
they're like we gotta run some tests
because
you can't leave
you got sick from the flu shot yeah
at 20. so this is 20 plus years ago
yeah and they came back and we're like
uh you have a certain gene variant that
like depending on certain uh flu vaccine
or whatever it could really uh create
some problems for you so i remember
telling the team doc i'm like i'm not
taking that ever again i was at 21.
you're like well i guess you're not
going to play i was like i don't give it
you know i don't care it was that bad
yeah like you know like two days of like
knowing that like you got to run tests
on me
and i just felt like um to be honest i
mean like i just felt like ncaa they
didn't give a damn you know the coaching
staff they didn't care they're like oh
well
you got to get it because it protects
everybody else and this and that we're
all you know traveling together this and
that and i'm like but
i almost died so like screw you like i
would miss a couple games i don't care
right so that was your close call yeah
how about yours pat dude
health and maybe you you know in the
army you used to party i'm not going to
count that stuff that stuff is just the
stuff is the
life self-inflicted you know some of
that stuff is self-inflicted but even
but i would say
forget the war in iran i'm talking
health like health as a situation like
something happens you catch bronchitis
or pollen all that all the drink and all
the stuff that i did it's just
you know in the army you drink tequila
one or two bottles of tequila every week
for two years straight so just think
about that yeah so if you noticed if you
notice the stock of jose cueva are doing
good from 97.99
thanks pb i owe you some money
[Laughter]
and i was a great recruiter as well yes
i never dreamed alone yeah and i said
guys come on hey guys
big meeting big meeting huddle up it's
our monday motivation
by the way one of these days felix and
bradford's got to tell these stories of
how it was in the army anyway so for me
yeah i had bronchitis sucked right
pneumonia just in the last 15 years i
had it it sucked in the army i had a
dehydration situation which was terrible
because i was digging a foxhole and i
was trying to be such a you know a great
soldier that i dug up six foxholes six
feet by three feet by six feet
in cat four cat five in you know south
carolina in the heat in july august
which is the worst time to do so got
completely dehydrated was in a hospital
they had ivs on me left and right so
i've had a lot of those instances where
i pushed the envelope but allergy would
pollen believe it or not yeah i was in
the emergency room for like straight 13
times in a span of two weeks uh
uh uh first six months of 2019.
right now i can't breathe damn i just
couldn't breathe two years ago yeah it's
two years ago obviously i didn't
announce it i said i don't i don't
allergic but it was kicking my ass i
thought it's over with right i thought
i'm like jen jim would hold my hands i'm
like i can't breathe jen so we'd go
straight to ur middle of the night one
o'clock two o'clock in the morning right
pollen and i asked the doctor so where
should i live the doctor said you should
be as close to the ocean as possible
that's all you have to say
right all right
i'm gonna do such a house in front of
the water because the doctor said so
right
now
what about the story you talked about
when you were doing the php tour and you
oh yeah
but that was because i was just pushing
sometimes yeah i don't mind those uh
exhaustion from working too i don't mind
those because those happen once every
other year once every three years i get
one of those right just go in and a
doctor says your body is just telling
you you got to shut it down for a couple
days you get a few ivs you come out
sleep sleep sleep underrated underrated
yeah so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]